this is a production of Cornell
University
hi I'm Frank Rossi
self as an urban grassland ecologist for
the purposes of this like this the earth
is warming it's our fault we are as
we've seen and grant showed moving into
cities at rapid rates which is a good
thing because then we only mess up small
amounts of area every place we go we
tend to mess things up as a population
and one of the things that we know is as
we move into these urban environments
and I know my colleague Nina Bostick has
been barking about this for 40 years and
hardly anybody has been listening but
it's very important to have plants and
green infrastructures in these systems
as yoshi said very well to start us off
today not growing food but supplying us
in different ways so it's really
important that we have these green
infrastructures there the problem is
people can't be trusted to take care of
them they mismanaged nutrients they mow
improperly they don't store the water
resource exceptionally well there's
enormous amounts of emissions associated
with their use they don't know how to
deal with organic waste let me never
mind their adherence to pest management
principles so these improper practices
are all leading to a reduction in
ecosystem services and that really is
fundamentally where there's no longer a
letting that laughing matter how these
landscapes provide and regulate the
support and in my perspective our offer
all these cultural services the human
well-being the recreation that urban
grasslands can provide so our research
is focusing on diversified plantings
mixing c3 and c4 plants in lawns in
hopes that it can be a little bit
smarter when the water comes and goes
that's one approach the other is to take
the people out because in my opinion
they can't be trusted is to automate
those landscapes and we have as the six
million dollar man who's old enough you
know anybody my age would remember that
television show we have the technology
to do this now it's a matter of making
it work and systematizing it so that
works on a smartphone and so we have an
array of robotic mowing technologies
an array of irrigation moisture sensing
technologies the ability to hand the
keys of the mowing over to the robot
which will be much better than a regular
person mowing and turn the keys of the
irrigation system over to the soil
moisture sensors after they're
calibrated so that the water can be
applied properly and in conjunction what
that will then lead to you know is sort
of like driverless cars right the roads
are going to have to be a little bit
different the roads will be used more
efficiently and we'll all be quite a bit
safer when humans aren't driving and in
my hope just like it might be illegal
someday to drive a car i hope it's
illegal to mow your this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu